it was right when we rented the bigger  Studio yeah and so all of a sudden we  had then more rent to pay and that was  scary yeah it was like if people aren't  on patreon aren't happy then that  money's gonna go away and then we have  to just you know that's another lease on  top of this apartment I just collect  leases isn't that just life yeah kind of  you're trying to collect a car lease a  house lease you know a four-wheeler  lease you want to be in as much debt as  possible yeah that's the American way  yeah to own nothing and that is  financial advice yeah record it SEC book  us  being as much dead as possible yeah the  thing is they would like that yeah  they're like yeah yeah yeah let's go for  the economy yeah yeah dump your savings  yeah